Well, I have everything I need,...
...but do you have any questions for me about the company or the position?
Yes. Imagine you're looking back on this hiring decision in a year.
The person you hired has exceeded your expectations.
What did he or she do that impressed you the most?
That's a great question.
I think in one year the person would have come in...
...and spent some time learning from the team and people that have been here a while.
Then, she or he will begin making changes in an informed way.
In one year, I want this person's team to be a well-oiled machine.
I want them to be bouncing ideas off each other,...
...coming up with new designs, and making headway into new markets.
That's helpful.
It's good to know what the expectations are.